أعتقد أنه من الصعب ولكن أيضًا
وجهات نظر رائعة ، فنحن نرسم
فقاعات قدمي الصغيرة لنفهم أن
شدة الشعور الذي نمتلكه بالنسبة لهم
هناك أمة وربما حتى
الأمة العربية بأكملها التي
تقف وراءهم تمامًا كرأس أكبر
أنه من المحتمل جدًا أنه أشهر
مصري في العالم في الوقت الحالي
[تصفيق
] ، لم يقتصر التملق على
ليفربول فقط أو في الوطن في مصر هذا
العام ، فقد انتشرت
مشاركاته اليومية على نطاق واسع إما من قبل حشد
من المتابعين.  على Twitter و
Instagram ، يعتبر رجل عائلة
متواضع مع مكانة نجم
جاذبية واضحة للعلامات التجارية الكبرى مما يجعل سالم واحدًا
من الرياضيين العرب الأعلى دخلاً في
جيله ، الناس في جميع أنحاء العالم
يعبدونك الآن ولكن بشكل خاص هؤلاء
الشباب وأنت تأخذ ذلك
المسؤولية على محمل الجد ، وإذا
كنت ترغب بشدة في أن تكون جزءًا
من مبادرة أدوية الطاقة ، على
سبيل المثال ، أخبرني عنها عندما طلبوا
مني القيام بذلك ، فقلت نعم لـ c  سوف
أفعل ذلك في ديفون وأنا أحب هذا ، وأحب أن
أشعر أنني أساعد الناس
والجميع بالنسبة لي مثل نموذج يحتذى به